cette conductrice de métro à la ratp sur
la ligne 9
vous êtes une maman célibataire de deux
enfants vous gagnez 1550 euros net par
mois hors primes
tout à fait et aujourd'hui vous dites je
travaille en horaires décalés selon
l'ouverture des lignes de métro pas de
week-end pas de jours fériés la nuit
avec deux enfants c'est extrêmement
compliqué puisque vos horaires de
travail c'est de 5 heures à 11h30 ou de
18h45 à 1h15 du matin on est bien
content donc vous devez faire forcément
garder vos enfants alors votre famille
peut pas se peut pas tout le temps donc
forcément vous devez prendre une ou qui
vous coûte 300 euros par mois
donc c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui vous
sentez étouffer complètement bord déjà
dû revenir déjà sur cette journée de
manifestations déjà j'ai vu qu'il avait
plus d'un million de travailleurs dehors
et pas que les 3% de régimes spéciaux
qui étaient dans la rue y avait des gens
du privé quand j'étais à manifestation
cet après midi il est de degré j'ai vu
des ouvriers
j'ai vu des serveuses j'ai vu des femmes
de ménage j'ai vu des chômeurs j'ai vu
des retraités
j'avais des directeurs de pme pmi j'ai
vu toute la france oui dehors j'ai
croisé tous les français donc c'est pas
que les
j'ai une question qui est dans la rue
c'était tout le monde réuni s'étaient
tous les atouts les travailleurs plus
qu'en 2010 je suis pas surpris enfin je
vous interdis pas surpris moi j'avais
dis depuis un mois et demi que la grève
du sein qu'elle allait être suivi est
très suivie et moi je m'étais rendu
justement notamment à la ratp à la sncf
et on a déjà débattu ensemble
je m'étais rendu dans les entrepôts et
justement pour comprendre un peu quels
étaient les ressorts et je disais à mes
collègues du gouvernement qui avait
évidemment un peu le sujet des retraites
mais pas que d'ailleurs y compris à la
ratp quand j'y vais et que je pose la
question à des jeunes et des moins
jeunes quels sont les sujets mais
évidemment il ya sujet des retraites
parce qu'on a du mal à savoir où va le
gouvernement met à nos conditions de
travail a le travail de nuit et à la
rémunération l'évolution des métiers etc
l'ouverture à la concurrence et donc moi
je prends le chef injuste ce n'est pas
pour moi en tant que membre du
gouvernement en charge des transports il
est global et évidemment les retraites
mais moi ce que je veux pouvoir offrir
j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion d'en
débattre c'est quand même un avenir pour
ces boîtes qui sont franchement des
boîtes assez extraordinaire des vrais
outils industriels et je vous vois je
vais vous faire un d'avenir qu'il soit
un avenir désirable
après j'entends le moment de frustration
qu'elle veut dire plus que ce que veut
dire irène je pense
monsieur desmarest en fait ce qu'elle
veut dire s'est il y avait un million de
français de tous bords
est ce que le gouvernement est ce que
les autorités ont entendu cela où ils
disent ça va être le 5 décembre ça va
passer ça va se calmer on va attendre
voilà c'est ce que vous vouliez dire un
peu irréel vous dites que vous êtes venu
nous voir
oui tout à fait vous êtes passé sur la
ligne du 9 vous n'êtes pas vu le début
des travaux est venue il ya quelques
semaines soit ligne de métro la ligne 9
oui vous êtes venus voir les cadres non
vous a pas vu en bas personnellement ce
que nous faisons pas vu après avec qui
vous êtes allé voir mais j'ai pas vu
tout le monde mais devraient venir voir
les gens qui s'en bat les solutions
contrôleur ce matin à 6h du mat j'étais
pas avec des cadres j'étais avec des
gens qu'ils aient l'information sur des
voyageurs docteur dites moi pourquoi
vous avez manifesté aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui manifestement là je suis
aussi sans revenir sur sur mon cas moi
voilà c'est ça ouais donc voilà donc je
suis aussi délégué unsa ratp à mts et au
rer d'accord informations donc moi quand
vous dites que vous connaissez très bien
il vous connaissent aussi très bien
alors moi j'ai commencé à travailler
dans le privé
j'avais 21 ans je suis rentré l'air atp
à 33 ans en 2015 d'après match je
perçois aujourd'hui un salaire d'environ
1000 utilisé comme vous dites 1950 1600
euros nets avec les primes ce fut un peu
moins de 1000 euros
les primes ont les deux sens en
fluctuant sabathia des yankees chargé me
disant tu domines 2800 euros de rien je
pense un pas mais 8 mai 2008 et mai 2009
écrit moi là je suis à peu près à 1800
1900 euros
quand je suis en vacances par an plus
sur le mois d'août j'aurais pas ces
primes là je suis malade j'aurais passé
première fois quand mes enfants sont
malades j'aurais pas ces primes là donc
ça sociaux de calais vous avez besoin
bien sûr de ses primes pour pouvoir
vivre parce que sinon vous en sortez pas
exactement parce qu'aujourd'hui avec
1600 euros en france en ne s'en sort pas
je sais pas comment les gens aussi que
la ratp est plutôt une bonne boîte y
compris pour les mères isolées
ils font plein de trucs sur les crèches
sur le logement à non juste
je vous dirais d'averse est simple moi
quand je commence je dois ouvrir mon
métro à 5 heures du matin à 3h30 j'ai
pas de crèche j'ai pas de centre bien
sûr moi j'avais ma maman de 70 ans qui
doit venir à la maison où je dois aller
déposer mes enfants le camp je suis de
nuit à garde aussi mes enfants ce qui
veut dire que quand je finis à 2 heures
30 le vendredi ou le samedi
elle va jusqu'à 2h30 le métro eh ben je
rentre je dors je vais devoir me
réveiller pour aller chercher les
enfants pour les déposer à l'école
bien sûr répond des exemples concrets ce
soir voilà comme vous irène donc vous
vous avez manifesté pourquoi pas ce
qu'on vous demande de travailler plus
pour gagner moins c'est ce que vous
dites vous me demandez de travailler
plus en des années en plus comme vous
demandez à un câlin un carreleur un
plombier un mât soignait de train de
travailler encore plus alors qu'on est
déjà brisé en faites pas enfin c'est pas
ce qu'on demande si vous aussi vous si
vous demandez à tous pour jouer aux
commandes mais c'est parce qu'on est
d'accord demande pas aux gens de
travailler plus d'abord les gens en vrai
enfin on pourra se parler du système d
oka nous envoie les gens ils travaillent
déjà plus de 100 patients apprennent à
l'atp mais les gens ils pour qui peuvent
partir à 62 ans
en moyenne ils partent 4 63 64 donc le
système il est déjà ils paieraient pas
mais moi je m'attache 480
vous avez ensuite nous ce qu'on dit
c'est pas qu'on veut c'est pas qu'on
veut que les gens travaillent plus avec
les gens perçoivent moi j'aime bien mais
ce qui s'est passé en fait il le rapport
delevoye et notamment les syndicats ont
pris le rapport delevoye strictement l
on dit voilà ce qui va se passer et vous
avez fait des tracts en disant vous
allez perdre 30 à 40% de pension avant
même qu'on ait commencé ni enfin à poser
les bases de discussions entre les
syndicats et avoir un projet de loi
hyper concret donc en fait on en train
d'avoir de nous on a des tracts
syndicaux qui nous disent vous allez
voir tout le monde va y perdre alors
qu'on n'a pas encore posé le stylo sur
ce que met le texte parce que ça quand
même qu'ils savaient pas augmenter les
retraites en baissant le nombre de
cotisants retraités vont augmenter pour
les enseignants les retraités vont
augmenter pour les agriculteurs sagan
combien un agriculteur à la enfin moi je
venais d'être apte vous avec des rythmes
élus du nîmes où jamais exactement vous
des exemples concrets les yeux d'une
limousine donc auto sans que la raison
voudrait peut-être un tract avec des
réponses wire voilà au problème mais
alors je réponde concrètement par un ou
deux exemples on a toujours dit que les
enseignants aient émis chez jean michel
blanquer a rappelé qu'ils avaient un
problème de rémunération des enseignants
et on a dit que la conséquence de la
réforme des retraites salle est
justement de revoir le système de
rémunération des enseignants au début de
carrière
des lois des jeux prend un autre
retraité d'autre part la régénération 2
ans vous êtes dans les faits on a mis un
truc concret on a dit pas de retraite en
deçà de 1000 euros nets pour une
carrière complète ni le roannais 1000
euros nets mais le renommer chez moi qui
vit aujourd'hui avec 1000 euros n'est
d'accord mais on peut bien dire que là
c'est pas une avancée et tuteurs aux
agriculteurs dans mon territoire mais
500 euros non plus un exemple concret
brian gallagher dans mon territoire la
plupart et gagner entre 4 et 7 100 euros
par mois 4 et 7 soit au moment de se
mettre en forme c'est grave mais c'est
aujourd'hui ça berlin - avec la réforme
c'est 1000 euros net alors donc ça va
mettre près un quart étaient encore les
femmes parce que les les femmes n'ont
pas une car la plaine y aurait on a des
enfants
ben on en construit des pontons pour
cent des gens qui mettent à temps
partiel se sont si les femmes ouais
voilà donc je dis aujourd'hui je vais
finir par aimer la baisse en main parce
que pourquoi est ce que je serais pas là
dans la rue parce que avec 2 degrés c
est ce qu'on va faire fin d'un projet
qui est prévu vous savez ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va donner des droits
aux femmes dès le premier enfant
aujourd'hui vous avez une majoration de
tension quand vous avez trois enfants
c'est 10 % de majoration dans le projet
ça c'est triste de le voir
qu'est ce qu'on vous a fait dans le
projet enfin les merdes d'amateurs
justement le gérez-vous nous enlever à
nous mêler surcroît détrompons nous amis
on va pas enlever abbès vous avez 10 %
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui 10 % au bout du troisième
enfant dans le projet vous avez 5 % au
bout du premier enfant de majoration de
10 % le deuxième 15 63e donc non
seulement on va rien enlever les
cauchemars ajouté c'est plus et c'est le
premier enfant
c'est l'institut de la protection
sociale a fait le calcul est dans mes
réflexions et le début c'est qu'en fait
à cause de votre changement et la prise
en compte de la ferrière complète et ce
à la grande nouveauté et nous les femmes
on a du mal en début de carrière d'avoir
des hauts salaires
on est très mauvaise pour négocier des
hausses de salaire pendant la carrière
ce qui sait que si vous prenez tout
notre vie nécessairement nous allons y
perdre que l'eau coule clinique est
prévu pour ajouter pour nous les mamans
ça ne compense en rien et pas du tout de
très loin ce que vous nous enlever en
changeant
juste un truc à les acculer les été fait
sur l'ensemble de la carrière qu'on
appelle le conseil d'orientation des
retraites il a fait le calcul
et il a dit que le système quel tel que
le propose et jean paul delevoye
il était avantageux pour les 40% alors
des français les moins aisés juste pour
voir jean baptisé baril et parmi ceux-là
les femmes
donc on peut changer les chiffres moi ce
que je vois là c'est que vous êtes en
train de dire donc que tous les gens qui
sont dans la rue c'est parce qu'il ya
une incompréhension je saluerai établit
des faits voilà j'arrête les gens ne
comprennent pas moi je sais pas c'est
pas mon repos j'ai juste que quand on
dit quand on dit que aujourd'hui système
les biens gino il pas bien d'accord
par exemple philippe martinez unis c'est
le meilleur système du monde bah moi je
dis oui sauf pour les agriculteurs sauf
pour les femmes que voulu travailler
plus et ont 40% de pension moins que les
hommes encre avait là sauf pour les
arrivées non mais c'est pas vrai ça si
vous faites on est d'accord que nous on
a des carrières to ride
à la fin on a nous les femmes on 40%
seulement quelques augmentations de
salaire quand on arrive un peu avoir
l'audace de dire à nos patrons augmenté
nous alors que toute notre vie on a des
salaires inférieurs
en quoi est-ce que la prise en compte de
notre premier euro de salaire depuis
cantonné aux gamines bas nous arranger
en fait on vous allez nécessaire mais
bien parce que déjà vous avez dit deux
choses justes vous avez dit d'abord il
ya les et des inégalités salariales
entre les hommes et les femmes mais je
pense qu'on peut quand même dire que le
gouvernement tente de les réduire on
pourra toujours dire que c'est pas assez
mais enfin vous avez reçue marlène
schiappa ici c'est son combat en
particulier f
et d'ailleurs ça a déjà réduit c'est
aussi le fruit des quinquennat précédent
pour le coup et deuxièmement parce que
justement ces carrières à trous des
femmes
on va aller combler par des points
supplémentaires je veux être hyper
concret je les dis je les dis j'ai dit
des points effectivement pour le fonds
des majorations de pension pour premier
deuxième troisième enfant et il y aura
des points aussi pour les périodes de
maternité aujourd'hui ça n'existe pas
donc enfin lé tri mais j'aimerais qu'on
vienne sourire est moins de savoir si
vous n'avez pas de vous n'avez pas
d'aujourd'hui devrait confier devant
tous les français voyaient gaz et dans
tous les français aucun problème c'est
écrit qu' aujourd'hui personne personne
va perdre 1 euro avec votre effarement
je m'engage pas je m'engage je ne sais
pas non mais on est d'accord mais jeudi
pour les 40 %
je vis des autres choses parce
qu'effectivement dans le système on a
dit on va repenser un peu on va essayer
de
eux de faire en sorte que les carrières
qui sont enfin bref que les 40 % les
plus pauvres du pays pour le dire
clairement et des pensions qu'il soit
augmenté c'est ça qu'on va essayer de
faire est évidemment quand vous
rééquilibrer un système quand vous lisez
ces goûts mais des inégalités vous avez
perdra pas elle sera pas touchée ça y
règne mais honnêtement elle a enfin
irène
à l'aller ce mois d'un régime spécial
c'est qu'est ce que vous appelez non
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui à la ratp pour arrêter avec
ça avec les régimes spéciaux 15e
spéciale
aujourd'hui on a quoi je vous entends
d'une partie à 64 ans moi je rentre à 33
ans elle ratp dont youtube en seulement
quatre ans on est d'accord vous avez
fait le calcul
vous voyez bien hop je vais partir avec
à peu près mille quatre cents euros
attendez donc du coup j'ai tué des
jeunes spéciale en temps je veux dire
aïe plus longtemps pour essayer d'abord
un minimum de 1500 euros pour essayer de
ne pas compter sur mes enfants eh bien
vous savez quand j'ai appris à ne pas
devoir quoi alors - en fait je revienne
et un chiffre n est pas tu sais combien
aujourd'hui entre 2000 et 2500 euros
mais bon on va faire monsieur devait pas
arriver à une solution web à un chiffre
vous savez il ya eu un sujet sur l'âge
pivot sais pas si vous avez suivi un
petit peu ça en disant on va essayer de
faire en sorte qu'ils aient un ajout à
34 ans 64 ans pour que tout le monde
tout le monde tous les français quelles
que soient leurs conditions puissent
partir avec 100% de retraite 64 ans
c'est un gain en général de trois ans
pour les femmes parce qu'aujourd'hui on
a beaucoup de femmes qui parce qu'elles
ont des carrières hachées sont l'objet
de poursuites jusqu'à 67 ans l'âge de la
jeunesse que dire et voilà et je dis
qu'avec le système et ça je peux vous
l'écrire aussi puisque c'est marqué dans
le rapport avec le système demain
personnes partira et je comprends
choisir de travailler plus longtemps de
cotiser plus longtemps et même personne
alors on de retraite ça veut rien dire
votre qu'on connaît pas la valeur du
point
on connaissait la pratique le 5 décembre
à balances ton post vous allez prendre
lé grand engagement sur l'honneur
vous allez vers mais moi je les ai cru
je vomis malchin sauf que la valeur du
point
rapport rapport je le vois dire
on va répondre injuste irène pourquoi
vous avez manifesté
qu'est ce que vous voulez qu'elle est
votre revendication vous je sais que
vous vous dites il faut augmenter les
salaires des agents de la ratp sur les
pdg vient d'être nommé degert tous vers
2 5%
tout a pas de raison que l'on dit ont
presque pas été augmenté depuis dix ans
c'est vrai que ça c'est fou c'est pas
moi tout ça parce que là je voudrais
conduire dans les crimes à un nom je
veux des rues de paris est ce que c'est
vrai le mois qu'a demandé le pdg de la
ratp vient d'être augmentée l'avait dit
exactement vient d'être augmenté de 12,5
pour cent c'est vrai pendant l'été a été
augmentée de 12 500 et 1000 euros
je n'avais pas été augmenté depuis dix
ans voilà vingt europe et 1 30 euros pas
plus depuis puis comme un temps fort dès
2015 et aux moyens de vivre peut-être de
pipriac moi je vous dis depuis quoi
depuis quatre ans at il fallu 5 6 en
même temps 25 ans je calcule pas les 0,1
et 0,2 moi je commencerai à dire je suis
contente quand on aura peut-être de
chauvé pas des 0,1 mais je veux dire
deux choses je comprends que 12 de
prôner la colère de dire et aux salaires
ça choque par contre moi j'ai regardé
les chiffres
en dix ans elle est un cap et non mais
je vais je suis écouté puis on aidera à
l'occasion fut de salaire en disant à la
ratp l'ensemble des personnels elle te
conter plus vérifier ça fait 3 % par an
en pleine mer 3 % c'est pas énorme et
l'inflation etc
mais c'est 30 ans 30 % pendant dix ans
donc c'est pas été bon mais moi j'ai pu
la voir dans la montée douce pour tous
il est juste on a vu cet été oui en une
fois mais moi je dis pas que ça choque
pas voilà c'est ça vous dit c'est juste
que celle du baril est mal imaginer nous
comment ça nous choque voilà c'est ça la
perception après ample et nous on entend
parler vrai on peut entrer dans le débat
elle est allée patronne d'une grande
boîte public
elle gagnera probablement plus dans le
privé vous mdax possible ya des mecs qui
gagnent des stars de foot qui viennent
de millions par mois avec un de pas
d'union par mois après on peut rentrer
dans tous ces débats là je dis juste que
moi je vois qui jusqu'aujourd'hui même
si un message et néry toujours n'ai rien
contre cette patronne est parti mais
aujourd'hui ce qui fait tourner les
trains les bus c'est nous ces nouvelles
jours dixit marc jeanjean dit dans
lesquels je dis c'est nous vous
comprenez est ce que est ce qu'il est
envisageable d'avoir une augmentation de
salaire pour les agents de la ratp ou
pas du tout enfin jeudi a laissé leur
nom
avoir une autre voie là c'est sa voix la
seleçao dites-moi est-ce qu'on aura
manuel obligatoires sur les salaires
chaque année et c'est pour les gens à la
négo n'y a pas de terme à linge chacun
en moyenne chaque année en moyenne les
salaires la ratp chaque année en moyenne
celui du t1 année augmente de 3% et
après moi je les dis notamment notamment
pour la réforme des retraites il y aura
des choses à faire dans l'entreprise je
les dis à catherine guillouard la pdg de
la ratp on demandera évidemment dans le
cadre du rpt de la refonte du système de
retraite doit réfléchir à des retraites
complémentaires etc etc alors y règne
juste vous est ce que vous aller
reconduire cette grève alors ce matin en
était à 5 heures du matin dans les ag
avec tous les conducteurs d'accord
agents ratp bas que les conducteurs
c'est reconduit donc on va demain
d'entraînement et qu'est ce que vous
attendez à l'origine pour que vous
cessiez d'ailleurs le retrait total de
cette réforme nous n'en voulons pas les
français m'en veulent
[Applaudissements]
vous sûrement vous avez pas perdu
d'argent moi j'ai perdu de l'argent
beaucoup de fois sans perdu de l'argent
aujourd'hui le vent dit les français
n'en veulent pas mais quand on garde
ok alors c'est alors soit on joue les
falloir 69% des français soutiennent la
grève
ouais et 76% des français veulent une
réforme du système des retraites en
profite bat très fort mais si bonne
pourquoi vous en faites pas cadeau aux
policiers et pourquoi on en fait pas
cadeau aux députés c'est pourquoi vous
voulez retirer ses réformes je me suis
cassé leur à dire ça a déjà calé parle
c'est vrai ce que vous savez ce que vous
promettez moi j'ai été député avant et
je faisais pas de politique à la broche
serait pathétique après mois jette le
premier truc qu'on a fait voter le
projet de loi qu'on a fait voter c'est
la loi qui a annulé le régime spécial de
retraite des parlementaires
sinon qu'il est en fait très bien
fonctionné il en savait faut continuer
dans ce sens et vous savez combien ça
fait de pourcentage
on s'est fait moins 37 2 5% parce qu'on
a estimé m attend dé moi je peux pas les
parlementaires mais je dis juste que au
moins nous on sait appliquer à
nous-mêmes ce qu'on disait à bonson
clame haut et fort il méritait aucune
espèce de prime parce qu'il y ait aucun
autre magasin mais juste il est plein de
leçons ya plein de gens qui donnent des
leçons il faut jamais si c'est ça
wasquehal on attend pour bernard laporte
non mais il a raison de dire qu'ils le
font moins et ça il faut le respecter
c'est comme quand il te dira quelque 5%
pour le voir enfin que ça n'existait pas
chez camille d'avancé je dis pas je dis
pas que tout est nickel
il ya quand même une avancée on peut pas
toujours tout critiquer c'est pas
débattre raquette moi c'est vrai qu'on
revienne sourire elle est iranienne dont
vous vous allez continuer la grève
demain pas que demain pas qu'elle doit
ça peut coûter combien tempête s'évacue
style très longtemps comme un nouveau
nom va continuer parce que aujourd'hui
si on est prêt à perdre sur notre
retraité entre 400 et 700 euros jour là
près de six monnaies nous on a eu notre
treizième mois
vous savez qu'on peut te continuer
facile facilement jusqu'à quelques
années on alors à fêter le jour de l'an
on doit aussi réussi à plat ce que vous
dites mais des entraves aux gens à tous
les gens que vous allez bloqué qui
n'iront pas travailler qui ne sont pas
de votre avis qui ne pourront pas faire
garder leurs enfants aux entreprises qui
ne pourront pas ouvrir aux magasins qui
ne pourront pas ouvrir alors qu'ils sont
déjà fait une année du la joaillerie
fine se louent leur dit à ces gens là
parce qu'il ya comme une réalité dans le
pays moi je vais bien a touché au lié à
un moment mais qui sont touchés aussi
mais eugeot 6e demain quand qu'on ne
vous ne pouvez pas aller travailler que
vous ne gagnez pas d'argent que vous ne
pouvez pas faire garder vos enfants et
vous n'avez pas choisi le faillitaire la
grève vous bloquer le pays mais nous
réfléchir les autres à penser comme vous
et vous sortirez gagnants de la réforme
est-ce que vous avez la capacité blocage
et quand tu auras la négociation de
sortie de grève
vous vous fera gagner mais tout ça non
pas tout le moins pas d'amour le bébé
vous savez bien qu'on leur fera aucun
cadeau et vous imprimez pour l'uruguay
dans ma famille on découpe et madame
vous garderez vous garderez votre
situation et certains avantages que vous
avez vous pouvez pas nier le calcul de
la retraite c'est pas comme dans le
privé est par contre ceux qui n'ont pas
choisi de faire la grève
e mail peux vous dire ils ne gagneront
rien et personne n'a la bourse et de
tout ce qu'ils auront perdre alors vous
savez c'est pas normal cela répondre
quand j'ai fait quand justement avec
l'unsa on a fait le tractage dans
plusieurs gares ce comme vous dites 75%
des personnes nous ont dit vous avez de
la chance de pouvoir faire cette grève
fait de la chance donc pas un vrai bien
pouvoir faire cette grève
il ne faut pas les empêcher de
travailler très grandes banques belges
pas de travailler
[Applaudissements]
jabil sympa que quitterait pas fermer d
agréer monsieur de monsieur non mais
c'est vrai que ces gens là à exiger des
arts et des liens contournement il ya
plein de gens qui ont des boutiques
n'ont pas travaillé au maître décembre
ça fait un nom déjà qui travaille plus
il ya plein de boutiques au fait qu'il
ait ce plan de baisses de 30 barrages et
habitez vous à leur place ou chez les
remparts le plus de minutes et la région
elle défendrait pas son boulot elle va
elle défend ses idées mais de vous
parler plus sirènes de votre salaire que
la retraite en réalité surtout ces
voleurs je travaille autant beaucoup de
gens trouver la ratp la sncf les régimes
spéciaux edf gdf
moi je pars à 64 ans donc faut arrêter
les légendes également sa langue que
donc voir moi je consomme trop la cour
des comptes à sortir un chiffre deux
premiers 700 euros moi je ne touche pas
tomber cette fin heureuse je sais pas
sûr qu'ils ont fait ce chiffre se
chiffrent pense qu'il a été sorti en
prenant le salaire des cadres mais pas
des nôtres 3 700 euros j'étais jamais
touché je vois pas comment on peut
toucher par contre 700 euros et après
arrivé en retard je double mon salaire
ne me laissez un message suis d'accord
il pue le quoi il faut savoir la réalité
merci
je reconnais réalité on connaît la
réalité si on vit en moyenne un
conducteur de métro à la ratp en moyenne
ils gagnent 2600 euros net par mois
c'est pas moi non mais vous y êtes vous
par contre un peu tard trente trois ans
par rapport à d'autres moi je trouve que
ça allait mais par rapport à d'autres
mois une fois qu'on mène ses 27 ans bon
bref
mais en moyenne si on se dit les choses
en main alors peut-être le conducteur
qui va naître chez 2006 avoir c'est
celui qui fera peut-être suivi nuit qui
a fait l'histoire
les chiens moi j'avais des vrais
chiffres je voudrais saint-gobain euros
non touche pas de regarder les vrais
chiffres en moyenne à me dire qu'il ya
des gens qui font beaucoup de mai vous
savez moi je suis pas polémique j'essaie
de moi je suis là je sais vous vous
parle mon entreprise je dirais que ça
veut dire qu'il est des métiers viennent
plus oui on voit des cadres à vos
comptes et aux normes à l'horizon mais
non non en moyenne conducteur du train
non ça sourit conducteur je peux pas
valider ça alors venez la prefon alors
enfin la ligne 9 quand vous venez
n'allez pas voir les cadres venez
descendez venez parler avec nous mais je
vais aller voir nos salaires et nos
bulletins de paie ne pas avoir gardé ma
fiche de paye mes cheveux de jais mari
je serai avec vous en ce moment vous
croire dans le grain vous êtes rentré à
33 ans ont gagné entre 2008 et 2009 par
mois avec les primes plus un 13ème mois
et les machinistes penser les jupes rien
je dis juste j'essaie de poser des chefs
au sein de courants soit le candidat au
début je serai à choisir des chiffres
qu'on sache de quoi il parlait pour les
ténors moyenne en moyenne 1 conducteurs
ratp en moyenne mieux carrière et gagne
2500 euros net par mois en moyenne et
jeudi et un autre chiffre qu'on peut
poser parce que je rebondis sur ce que
disait madame lancé aujourd'hui les
français payent pas la gym spéciaux moi
je dis pas 3700 euros les pensions ça
effectivement ces chiffres - la légende
des trois missions vous des vrais
chiffres est aujourd'hui dans les
régimes spéciaux comme dans à peu près
partout en france les populations et
vieilli ça veut dire qu'en fait vous
avez peu de cotisants pour beaucoup de
gens qui sont à la retraite je prends le
cas de la sncf challenge en parler juste
après cannes as puis à 140 milles
cheminot à la sncf qui paye aujourd'hui
la retraite de 250 une personne ça
chaque année ça coûte 3,3 milliards
d'euros et qui le paye c'est les
contribuables français